[Música]
yo soy cenote
soy luz y oscuridad
mis aguas se adornan con cortinas de
rayos de luz y se transforman en magia
yo soy cenote
soy flores que se convierten en jardines
soy una montaña subacuática o un bosque
soy en donde se encuentra el río con el
mar
[Música]
yo soy semana que estoy contaminada
aguas residuales se filtran por el suelo
hasta llegar a mí
fertilizantes y químicos son mi mayor
amenaza
[Música]
necesito tu ayuda tanto como tú
necesitas mi amigo
hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevistada
de france 24 en español
estábamos viendo recientemente imágenes
de yo soy se note hablamos de una pieza
audiovisual que cautiva por la belleza
de sus imágenes pero que no se queda
allí y que es todo un grito de ayuda
para el agua y para los miles de cenotes
que también conoce desde tan pequeña
camina saberes a stern esta mexicana
quien le puso el cuerpo y también la voz
a soso y se nota y nos acompaña en esta
emisión de la entrevista camina saber
muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
france 24
horas santiago mucho gusto ahora espero
tenerme aquí bueno camina contanos cómo
surgió y cómo definirías yo soy se note
una obra que fue creada junto a dan ver
joven y que les recomendamos le contamos
al público que ganó el premio criticón
26 hablamos de un reconocimiento a las
propuestas artísticas que colaboran no
en afrontar la crisis climática y con
cuyas imágenes hemos vestido todo el
estudios de france 24
si yo soy sin antes una pieza que justo
quiere mostrar la belleza pero al mismo
tiempo la fragilidad de los cenotes está
inspirada en que los cenotes para mí
representan un lugar donde yo me siento
un refugio en paz y donde entreno apnea
y ledger a demostrarlo pero también este
llamado a que eso está en la gran
amenaza y el reconocimiento credit com
26 pues refuerza este mensaje refuerza
lo importante que es ahora camina bien
decía recientemente es un lugar donde te
sentís en paz verdad y te vemos en las
imágenes como una parte absolutamente
orgánica de los cenotes del agua que
sentís así también cuando estás en las
profundidades
sí sí la idea de practicar este deporte
es justo despertar como esa sensibilidad
con el agua estar en paz con este
elemento y que te permita hacer esas
inversiones a profundidad tengo la
fortuna de entrenar en ellos y pues
justo empiezo porque me despiertan está
esta paz sí creo que en el vídeo se
capta este mensaje pero también que son
frágiles y que
están en un gran peligro
absolutamente y los cenotes de la región
de la riviera maya son un ecosistema muy
particular verdad o sea no solo aparecen
como vemos en las imágenes espacios
mágicos no de asombro de enorme belleza
tiene una función crucial y muy
particular en la biodiversidad verdad
claro los cenotes son los ríos
subterráneos que tenemos en la península
es nuestra única
fuente de agua de agua dulce y también
tienen un papel muy importante con las
salidas los buenos son los manglares los
estéreos que también están conectados
con los ecosistemas marinos entonces el
inp lo delicado es que son todos
conectados entonces cuando se daña o se
contamina uno también se refleja en los
que está diaz entes y eventualmente en
el mar entonces creo que también ahí
despierta este gusto por el agua a
partir del mar y también regresando a
los de agua dulce como los cenotes ahora
camila creciste no desde niña estuviste
allí entre los cenotes en la gas en las
aguas de la riviera maya en este hermosa
de méxico ha sido ha sido una testigo de
primera mano de lo que ha sufrido la
degradación de estos espacios contános
cake de que fuiste testigo que pues que
pudiste ver
y pues desde chica los llevo haciendo
aplicar en los cenotes desde muy joven y
si conforme ha pasado el tiempo se ha
visto que el efecto de la presencia
humana así ha ido en incremento no hay
cenotes en los que hace unos dos años te
podías meter puedes nadar en cualquier
época del año y ahora ya hay alertas muy
contundentes de la ciudadanía que ya no
puedes entrar porque te puedes salir con
una infección no puedes salir con algún
daño porque pues no se tratan las aguas
residuales no están tratando entonces
creo que es algo muy impactante que en
mi periodo de vida se pueda ver este
efecto tan fuerte
en este sentido se podría decir que tu
asesor es el océano no de alguna manera
porque bueno es como si te meterás en
sus entrañas para traernos un mensaje
desde allí mismo
sí creo que el agua o la agua como me
gusta decirle para mí me inspira y me ha
formado como persona y creo que la apnea
me ha llevado a que esta relación se
enriquezca no y creo que también es un
poco mi deber de tener la oportunidad de
hacer aprender los cenotes también es mi
deber compartir este mensaje que busca
ayuda que busca protección y también
pues este reconocimiento ok con 26
muestra que es un mensaje que resuena
también a escala global no es fue una
aplicación con mucho artistas y fue y si
este fue el ganador significa que es un
mensaje que importa entonces para mí fue
muy reconfortante recibir este
reconocimiento
camila en el vídeo en yo soy se note ahí
hay un detalle que me llamó
particularmente la atención quisiera
dialogar lo contigo que tiene que ver
que así estás luciendo un vestido
mexicano que como has contado fue
abordado por tu abuela verdad hay así
como una suerte de bella simbología no
me refiero las tradiciones se transmiten
siempre no de cultura en cultura de
generación en generación al igual que la
necesidad de cuidar todos estos espacios
del medio ambiente el agua y los cenotes
si yo tuve la fortuna de que desde chica
me inculcaron estos temas no yo nací en
una isla y crecí cerca del mar entonces
desde chica fue educación ambiental muy
constante y creo que eso fue lo que hizo
que también formará mi carrera y mí
me desempeño así con tanto como
activista como deportista como mi
profesión entonces si definitivamente mi
familia tiene mucho que ver desde
siempre me inculcaron este respeto y
este cuidado entonces si es un poco que
se pasa por generación en generación y
también que pues transciende el tiempo
no está importancia de cuidar el medio
ambiente va más allá de generaciones
sino atraviesa la historia de la
humanidad en este momento es muy
relevante ahora algo clave en tu tarea
en tu deporte que vos podés lograr
combinar no tu pasión por la apnea con
su activismo o tu cuidado por el medio
ambiente que también es crucial haces
una actividad en la que bueno que se
presta muy fácilmente no para
combinarlas como atleta te motivan
muchas otras causas no sólo ganar
medallas romper récord como de hecho lo
has hecho a nivel nacional
y justo yo practico la apnea como
deporte como de alto rendimiento con
todo lo que conlleva entrenar un deporte
a este nivel y pero tengo la fortuna de
también que se ha vuelto como una forma
de expresión
la apnea tal vez no sea muy conocido
pero tiene este atractivo visual que me
ha llevado a hacer este tipo de campañas
que hacen que las personas se acerque en
el agua y también que conozcan el
deporte y ahora también pues a través
del arte este cuestionamiento de cómo
nos relacionamos con el agua que es algo
que espero que se quede claro en este
vídeo y hay algo que comentan bastante
en tus entrevistas que es esto un
alejamiento del arte por el arte no el
arte tiene que tener una función verdad
crear conciencia ayudar en algún aspecto
sí creo que
pues lo que inicia el arte a su concepto
es algo que te hace sentir no y si
podemos utilizar este sentimiento para
despertar conciencias para que lleve
acciones para que vaya más allá de la
experiencia creo que ahí te toma aún más
relevancia
estas piezas y creo que ser parte de
esta generación que os está cuestionando
a través de muchos medios por ejemplo el
arte para mí me enorgullece
varias veces has dicho camino que
todavía recordad saque el primer momento
en el que te sumerge en el agua
recordada que el abrazo cómo fue
y pues lo descubrí de muy pequeña en un
curso con el papa en un discovery apnea
y me acuerdo muy muy claro como mi
primer inmersión que fue pues con mala
técnica como como supe pero llegué a lo
que en ese momento en el fondo del mar
yo creo que entre 20 25 metros me
acuerdo voltear a arriba y ver como esta
columna de agua
impresionante y me desperté mucha
curiosidad me sentí como con curiosidad
no unos sentimientos sino como pues
mucha paz y ahí es me engancho no y de
ahí ya no he vuelto a otro a otra
disciplina muchos me gustan pero me he
dedicado y enfocado a la apnea camila
que viene de ahora en más se que
participas en muchísimos proyectos para
el cuidado del medio ambiente combinando
con el amiguismo contanos que se viene
ahora en más
sí pues estoy muy emocionada por este
reconocimiento porque abra puertas a
otros proyectos tengo por supuesto un
entrenamiento sigue en pie estoy
empezando a calentar motores para mí
imparte entrenamiento fuerte que
comienza en enero del próximo año para
con una competencia
en el verano vertical blue en julio
junio de 2022 entonces pues me emociona
mucho que se conozca más el deporte para
que haya más más apoyo al deporte pero
también que pues vaya de la mano con
esta conciencia que me gusta siempre
compartir termina nos queda un poco
menos de un minuto pero no quisiera
dejar de pedirte un mensaje sobre todo
para los jóvenes de quien hace parte no
en el sentido del cuidado del medio
ambiente y lo fundamental que es volver
de primera mano
así que eso creo que nuestra generación
está dejando muy claro que ya estamos
exigiendo acciones más que palabras
estamos buscando que las corporaciones
sean
responsables y sean justas con el
impacto que tiene en el medio ambiente y
creo que esta generación es la
generación del cambio porque estamos
conectados porque aquí estamos
impulsados por la esperanza y me
enorgullece mucho participar y creo que
es momento de que se escuche a los
jóvenes en estos temas que pues somos
los que más le importan porque es el
futuro camino a acabar muchísimas
gracias por tu presencia en la cajita de
france 24 un placer dialogar contigo
mucho gusto gracias gracias a ti
nuevamente ya nuestra audiencia como
siempre la invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france mit y
cuatro.com sigan con nosotros
bien